thank you everyone um and obviously you
don't really want to hear from me
because you've heard from me plenty um
these past six years and it's it's nice
to be retiring um in that sense it's
been a a long struggle
um it's
yeah
and immensely immensely pleased and
proud of my wife
um proud to have a home and proud that
we start a new chapter and and you know
get to be a normal family again um
two things i wanted to say really one
one
there are lots of thank yous
um to say a bit like a you know
a groom speech at a wedding um
so
thank you
everyone
i
you know
you know the foreign secretary
did promise to get nursing home she did
like
a groom speech at a wedding um
so
thank you to
um
everyone in parliament um i i
you know when i actually thank you for
the government first um you know the
foreign secretary did promise to get
nursing home and she did
um and that's been a long struggle um
lots of foreign office staff
have been working behind the scenes and
we haven't always agreed i've been
plenty rude enough in public at points
about them
but we had a lovely three days
with them
after naznen came home
very nurturing
very caring um very kind people
and
they got her home
so it is for us
over
a new chapter
a process of healing and recovery and
and going back to normal um and we'd be
just you know in the speaker's office
um you know well six years ago
we wouldn't have been treated with a
sort of grandeur and and reception that
that is here and it it is a great honor
um
i
am really grateful to tulip um to all of
the mps who have battled for nazalene um
we were saying one of the things that
was really striking on wednesday at the
debate in in parliament when leslie was
on the plane
um was actually on all sides
people were pleased
people recognized our injustice people
battled it pushed the government to be
honest keep the oven honest and and
um i'm hugely grateful for all of that
care and support
um
that came
because lots of people in the media
kept nazi in the light and in different
ways at different times and kept our
family story in the night and could see
the injustice
and it came because
lots of
people up and down the country
followed our story and cared um
i think
you know with campaigning um a lot of
people actually sent me that there's a
poem
by a man called um
constantine simeonov
um called
about waiting i'll wait for a lot of
people sent me just recently i hadn't
confess i hadn't i hadn't seen it before
but
you know it feels like i've spent six
years
conspicuously waiting
um
and and lots
and lots of people have waited with us
um and that waiting has kept her safe
and here we are
um so thank you to everyone who has been
part of bringing leslie home and for
making us whole again
um
the other thing to say is before i hand
over nothing of course
it is baby steps
baby steps for us as a family um on the
journey back to normal um
and and i have promised me um you know
that any questions i want to answer and
doesn't have to
um
there is a
lovely reunion
i am
super proud
of her strength and her survival
and
her grace
i'm so pleased she's back home with me
that she came home to us
um
we're still negotiating with her daddy's
allowed in the same bed as as gabriela
and nasmin
we'll get there um but
yeah it's
it's you know i think we'll we'll we'll
do this and then we will disappear off
and heal a bit
um
and uh yeah i do feel um honored that
we've got
roxanne here today as their family's
journey continues
um
but
yeah i i this is my retirement day and
and i'm thankful it has come so thank
you